Human beings love to laugh,...
...and the average adult laughs 17 times a day.
Humans love to laugh so much that there are actually industries built around laughter.
Jokes, sitcoms and comedians are all designed to get us laughing.
That's because laughing feels good.
For us it seems so natural,...
...but the funny thing is that humans are one of the only species that laughs.
Laughter is actually a complex response that involves many of the same skills used in solving problems.
Laughter is a great thing.
That's why we've all heard the saying, "Laughter is the best medicine."
There is strong evidence that laughter can actually improve health and help fight disease.
It is true that we've long known that the ability to laugh...
...is helpful to those coping with major illness and the stress of life's problems.
But researchers are now saying laughter can do a lot more.
It can basically bring balance to all the components of the immune system,...
...which helps us fight off diseases.